let's make Mochi grilled cheese it's all
good this is the best grilled cheese
I've made so far first things first we
gotta make the Mochi your sweet rice
flour this is the brand I use sugar and
water mix well until nice and smooth I
cover with a plastic wrap now we're
gonna microwave this for one minute
after a minute in the microwave we're
going to stir this up and we're going to
microwave again for one minute we're
gonna mix again for the second time and
for the last time we're gonna microwave
this for 30 seconds all right for my
bread I'm using brioche but you can use
any bread you want now get the Mochi and
spread it as evenly as possible now use
any cheese you like I'm using American
cheese add a knob of butter
then put a cover on top brioche tends to
burn quickly so we're going to toast
this nice and gently
the restaurant served it with cheese on
top so that's what we're gonna do since
we're recreating the dish
Mochi cheese toast when I had this in La
I just had to copy it